I turn to my right and say hello to my
colleague from the NFL Network NFL Media
Group covering the Cowboys expertly for
us good to see you James Slater how are
you good to see you glad to see your
lair when you're not the NFL Network
this is my non-network lair this is the
ultimate man cave this is what the NFL
Network would look like if they just let
me have my way I mean I saw that welcome
letter from 2003 in the dressing room I
knew I mean you're grandfathered and I
would imagine that you would get your
druthers over there you know I just
turned 50 so to be called grandfathered
in anyway good to see you your end up to
Oxnard later today right Cowboys are on
their way right now they are you know
and I love it that PCH Drive every year
such a treat yeah I know that I've
gotten the glamour beat when it comes to
covering the Cowboys in Oxnard and then
Jerry does this no boo party yes it's
ready every year and I think you've been
a couple of times I know Vince Vaughn
showed up a couple years back but I mean
there's nothing like covering that team
there really isn't I wasn't the one that
Vince was that I wasn't the one where I
absolutely elbowed Gil branch out of the
way from a baked crab ham roll it was
very it was very unfortunate but you
can't get between me and my favorite
baked crab man wrong Brant is amazing
isn't he he's going in the Hall I mean
he is so on it the way that he can
rattle off stats and information and
players is like absolutely fascinating
to me he knows Abraham Lincoln's 40 time
off the top of his head because of fact
Julius Caesar for six times for his leap
at the vertexes toga got in the way so
they had to agree reevaluate 36 inches
for Julius so the plane is out in the
air now the Cowboys plane is in the air
it's taking off I believe at one o'clock
Dallas times time so our number three on
this Rich Eisen show will we know of
Zeke's on that plane or not do we know
attentionally now a couple of the
Cowboys end up coming out here ahead of
camp okay
Tyron Smith has done it in the past I
know Zeke has done it in the past so we
may or may not have our answers but I'm
gonna be stationed in front of the camp
facility so I'll be able to let you know
on NFL Network if Zeke is in fact in the
plane but talking to a bunch of the
people people in the building
sources that I consider to be very
strong ones they all believe
that Zeke is gonna show up in fact he's
said that to a few people so I truly
believe that this was his team
management team wanting him in the
conversation of DAC and Amar'e now you
and I've kind of talked about this
the timing is interesting to me given
that he got called to principal's office
again and the Cowboys I mean when I
think about his principal office the
principal's office right the fact that
Jerry Jones who had been fetid in the
Hall of Fame weeks later was going on
the record and defending his running
back the way that he did and really
stuck with him and even this summer when
this Vegas incident happened Stephen
Jones went out of his way to say but
look what he's done in the community so
he's had a little bit of carte blanche
in Dallas and I don't know if it would
make sense for them to push this thing
it still feels a little premature I
think we can all agree the Cowboys are
gonna they know that he's a foundational
player they know that he's important to
that offense he's gonna get paid but
there are guys in front of them that I
think they need to get done sooner well
I mean there is a quarterback here yes
the say mean the dak Zeke draft class
totally changed the direction of this
French 100 person I know arguing about
that so they both have to get at some
point paid unless they have an issue
with Zeke's off the field behavior like
as you just mentioned being called to
the principal the mere fact again
nothing happened apparently there is
some sort of suit countersuit between
Zeke and the individual that was part of
security late night but he's out and
about in Vegas where things can happen I
don't need to tell you what we got to do
is just watch you know any of the
hangover movies you could see anything
can happen once you know midnight
strikes I know nothing about that
understood well you've seen the hangover
I'm saying is that is that do the
Cowboys you think have any hitch in
their long-term sign and giddyup with
Zeke because of the off the field stuff
I mean I think it's a factor but it's a
factor in anyone's job I mean if I had
gotten called to the principal's office
you know two times in my last four years
with an organization I said not only
thank you for dealing with all this but
now I want you to to pay me long term
the timing feels a little
off now with that being said the Cowboys
I'm told have an immense respect for
Zeke he is such a pro even when all of
that stuff was going on with the
suspension and the trial the one thing
I'll say about Zeke is he showed up to
practice and he worked his tail off he's
the type of guy that literally puts his
head down and gets to work so when I
heard about this holdout it just felt
like it was media spend to sort of push
the discussion yeah down the road but I
didn't truly believe and I still don't
believe that Zeke's gonna end up holding
out that's just what I believe having
covered him the last four years
sure so what about death why haven't the
Cowboys pulled the trigger on deck we
all know they have to sign him we all
know they're not gonna let him walk are
they gonna take the the Kirk Cousins
Washington Redskins plan and go
year-to-year yeah I mean like so what
are the what's the holdup here so I
reached out to my sources yesterday on
this and they said they're optimistic
this still gets done in training camp
but it would have been to probably have
gotten this thing done before Carson
Wentz because Carson obviously sucked
the market so they're gonna have to pay
him at least 30 million and over but
when you think about how cheap dak has
been playing the last couple of years in
the fact that he was so impressive in
his rookie campaign that Tony Romo
didn't even get a chance to compete it
says to you the respect they have for
this guy and just watching him so far in
OTAs and minicamp he looks different a
lot of people are sort of like laughed
at this idea of Kellen Warren Jon Kitna
taking over the offense but kitten is
such a mechanics guy it's put your foot
here put your elbow there and they said
that his mechanics in the pocket he
looks like a different player and his
body looks a lot more you know he's a
large guy I won't call him soft but you
know we used to give Romo all the heat
for that but he just looks like his
conditioning yes was that much more as a
matter of fact earlier this week I was
told he was up there throwing the ball
with guys like Jason Witten and Michael
Gallup so he stayed engaged this summer
but I just I don't think he's a type of
guy you have to worry about and I think
he is going to benefit from Kellen
Moore's creativity and Jon Kitna --zz
emphasis on mechanics in the details
Jane Slater here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so you think that gets done
training camp yeah Zeke's gonna show up
and get and go back to work and
we'll figure out what the contract is
when that hits right what about Amari
Cooper that is the one thing that I
can't seem to put my finger on
emori Cooper's camp doesn't leak a lot
so I've been trying to get a handle on
the Amari Cooper situation he's the
Kauai of the NFL Mauri is is one of the
most enigmatic fascinating guys in that
locker room when you go to his locker he
doesn't say much he's pretty quiet and
he's playing chess which adobea Lussier
and when you ask him to walk you through
a particular play he reminds me of
jordan Spieth when I used to interview
jordan Spieth in Dallas he would walk
you through every single route why he
chose that iron why it was that Club it
was fascinating to me that's Amari
Cooper so I think Amari sort of sort of
the the sly cat on this but I do believe
they get that done specifically because
Michael Thomas we've already heard the
Saints say we're gonna make him the
highest-paid receiver we have no problem
with that we've seen that he's not
reported to camp today do you as the
Cowboys organization really want to wait
and see what that number is before you
pay a Morrie Cooper I say get that one
done pretty quick unless the maari's
playing chess here and is like okay
um I'm fine let's just see what Michael
Thomas does first before I sign you got
yeah I know you guys are dealing with
DAC you know and put the put the Queen
and try and checkmate you know if you
heard one utterance about what a Maury
to meet his demands are what he wants I
mean that's the way the Cowboys wanted
yes he's a he is a fascinating player to
me this whole thing I mean to me
Dallas is set that defense is ridiculous
okay that defense to me last year and I
know this pisses Bears fans off and
anybody else who thinks their defense is
fast and and dynamic Dallas's defense
last year was the fastest defense I've
seen in years with with Lawrence up
front and now you got Robert Quinn
Robert Quinn is now involved yes you got
Shawn Lee to come back see Shawn Lee
Layton Vander is Jaylon Smith I mean
it's sort of an embarrassment of riches
I think the biggest thing for them is
gonna be that safety position okay they
didn't address it with Earl Thomas they
feel like they've got some guys that can
step up and up that's one of the
positions I'm gonna be watching a camp
just to see if they're looking at the
waiver wire if they're comfortable with
that position on defense that to me is
the only question work and it just but
it so there's
I guess this is my whole long way of
setting up the fact that here we are
again we're the Joneses just seemed to
they kind of like the the buzz that's a
little bit on the edge they like the
edge like that's can we just sign
everybody including the coach and just
be normal here just be kind of normal
just go in like they could win the Super
Bowl this year this is a true fact they
made it here to Los Angeles to the
second round of the playoffs last year
mm-hmm they lose obviously but you could
take another step you win enough games
in the regular season people have to go
to the Jones Mall and this is possible
in full pocketed I would think I thought
one of their signature games was the way
they played the Saints in Dallas I mean
I think everyone thought they were in
get buried in that game hit him in the
mouth it was and so when they galvanize
like that and and they've got such a
young team but I think what they were
missing with some of that veteran
leadership last year so acquiring
Randall Cobb I think is gonna be huge
for that offense getting Jason Witten
back is gonna be big and I've said to a
lot of people they have quietly put
together this roster that we haven't
been talking about because we've been
talking about Odell Beckham jr. and
Antonio Brown and the Raiders and levian
Bell and the Jets we haven't really
talked about the Cowboys and I think
maybe that's a good thing finally James
Slater here on the Rich Eisen show
Garrett how come he doesn't get the
credit I'm serious like again you just
mentioned that game against the Saints
everybody was ready for the Saints to go
ahead and steamroll yeah Cowboys okay
cuz he's that's all Jason does his clap
right that's the idea that's Jason he's
a clapper he's such a different guy too
away from the cameras he really is okay
give me give me something on that Jane
what do you got for women so he does
these off the it's it's a it's the
walk-off and so that's when he's not on
the podium and you sort of get real
Jason Garrett you hear him say it from
time to time well that's a discussion
over a bunch of lemonade's but he really
is this really interesting interested
person as a matter of fact funny story
about Jason I've got his number I'll
reach out from time to time he will not
return one text one called
no matter what the situation is if I'm
giving a heads-up about something coming
down the pike don't hear from him my dad
and I went up to the facility to do a
tour my dad obviously big Cowboys fan
growing up in Dallas
and Jason spent probably 10 15 minutes
with my father hmm
and I sent him this text message I said
I really really appreciate that that
meant a lot to me I get this text
message just it meant so much to see you
interacting with your dad now I get
where you get your personality and so I
wrote back so this is your number that's
sort of the dynamic of our relationship
right but really the reason why I say
everyone always says well they're
they're always a meteor awkward I'm like
well they've only had one losing season
under Jason Garrett and the players
speak pretty freely to me and not one of
them has thrown him under the bus he
continues to garner their respect their
attention you start hearing guys talk
the way that that he talks dak really
respects them so I think that's the
reason why Steven Jones and Jerry Jones
keep him around they respect him too but
I think they just haven't had a better
candidate I mean show me someone better
that the Cowboys would potentially go
after I'd rather go with the devil that
I know if I'm those guys then someone
that I don't well there is the head
coach of the Saints that everybody keeps
sucking at tying to Dallas you know and
you're assuming he wants to leave all
the autonomy that he has in New Orleans
do you think he's gonna have that in
Dallas Bill Parcells learned the hard
way I agree with you I hear you know you
or you are not wrong I assume he wants a
ten million dollar paycheck who Sean
Payton yeah oh I think it's gonna be
higher than that I think anywhere he
goes it's gonna be higher than that
certainly if the Saints win the Super
Bowl this year I think he starts with
Jon Gruden numbers which is nuts that's
crazy yeah so how does this play out do
you think give me give me give me the
scenario for the Dallas Cowboys season
best you can tell as you were heading up
to Oxnard California I first of all it
for me is what I'm saying I think this
is one of the most talented groups
they've had since 2014
but I think that six-game stretch at the
end of the season is gonna be rough
where they go
Foxborough they go Philadelphia they go
Chicago in the cold that is a rough
six-game stretch they need to win a lot
on the front ends and then split the
difference on the back yeah week 12 at
New Orleans then a Thursday night or
home for Buffalo okay well no wait
that's Thanksgiving okay and then at
Chicago the next week on Thursday night
in that amazing Dallas every
here does that back-to-back where they
have a Thursday night or swath because
Chicago let me make sure I can confirm
this
Chicago's at Detroit on Thanksgiving too
so that'll be a full complement of rest
of a Thursday night football game Wow
Dallas at Chicago that will be great
home for the Rams that Philadelphia home
for Washington that's and this is the
first year in franchise history that
they don't have back-to-back home games
so they're on the road every other week
that is true so this is good this will
be it this will be a tricky season but I
think they've got the talent there and I
truly don't believe any of these
contract issues are gonna become a
distraction I just I believe that
they're they I did not and I did the
damn schedule show James later you are
correct they are home away home away
throughout even home then by away yeah
they don't they don't have two in a row
anywhere
it's a tricky schedule travel wise for
sure so dad gets done Amari is up in the
air cuz he's playing chess and we have
no idea what's going on between his
temples and you think Zach Zeke's on the
plane later on today and and or he's
already here and he'll show up 100% now
we'll see if my uh my old takes exposed
show up on Twitter tomorrow what I'll
play tell you this year the the I don't
know who runs that do we normal run set
it's a great account great gene and I'll
say it on behalf of anybody on the NFL
Network okay old takes exposed take out
your pen and write it down as long as
you the old to and I say this with
respect but as long as you give your
opinion well based in facts and not just
saying it just so you can get a click or
just to do anything like so many other
people in our industry do that's your
your opinion
look I do take now informed and it
doesn't matter how old it is or freezing
or whatever it is noted bring it how's
that there we go
strong that's I could drop this it's
attached to something if I could drop
the microphone I would but if it's too
expensive and I have two more hours to
do people like to see people filled oh
yeah
I can't end this conversation with
something like that
it's way too much of a bummer great job
on good morning football as well I
appreciate that absolutely loved loved
loved seen you do in that show and that
that show is just on fire it's so much
fun it is it's a ton of fun good luck
with all your travels well we'll be
bringing you up to get some updates on
the Cowboys throughout this season happy
to do it
at James Slater at Jane Ashley Slater on
Instagram how come you can't get Jane
Slater on Twitter not James Slater is a
very popular name in England what a
chase Slater is very British apparently
so when if I go over for a London game
I'm gonna seek him out and I'm just
gonna shake that thing we can make this
happen and James Slater on Twitter five
followers following one person has never
tweeted she's gotta buy it gotta buy it
we can make this happen
yeah TJ I think TJ's gonna be the man
for the job social medias are I think it
will be more than happy to take to take
Jason James Slater out but an in
meantime at Slater NFL good to see you
thank you you got it James Slater will
be seen later on on NFL Network up the
road in studio and then in Oxnard later
on today for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app